foreign
hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear so I feel like I'm probably not
alone when I say that in my opinion
Roger corman's uh post cycle of movies
was absolutely the director's finest
work I mean you know he made zillions of
movies and he always made a profit but
those are my favorite and I kind of feel
like most people uh would agree with
that now I had seen almost all of them
uh at one time or another my favorite is
actually mask of the Red Death in case
you were interested but for whatever
reason this one that we're talking
talking about today had actually like
passed me by not really sure why I never
got around to seeing it uh so of course
I had to rectify this situation as soon
as possible and that's how I ended up
watching 1963's The Haunted Palace and
also maybe considering uh that maybe I
have two favorites now in the corpsman
poe movie Universe uh however lumping
the haunted Palace in with the PO movies
isn't really entirely Fair even though
it usually is is considered part of the
eight film cycle
because in spite of the name of the
movie and a couple lines of dialogue and
the fact that the title card reads Edgar
Allan Poe's The Haunted Palace and also
they spell Alan wrong with an e instead
of an a which is correct uh this is
actually not an adaptation of a post
story it's actually a loose adaptation
of an HP Lovecraft Novella the case of
Charles Dexter Ward so this is almost
like a stealth Lovecraft adaptation
uh matter of fact as far as I'm aware
this might have been the first like
major film to introduce the Necronomicon
uh the Cthulhu yagsathoth like all that
kind of stuff to a mainstream audience
um if there was an earlier one please
let me know but as far as I know this
was the kind of the first big movie to
do that now Roger Corman uh actually
initially intended this to be just like
a straightforward Lovecraft film a
Lovecraft adaptation but uh to his
annoyance American International
pictures otherwise known as AIP uh
wanted to tie it in with the poe
adaptations because they'd been so
successful so they actually made him
throw in a few lines from Edgar Allan
Poe's 1839 poem which is called The
Haunted Palace and made him give it that
name as well uh and that poem actually
doesn't really have anything to do with
the story
um you know I get why they did it but
you know it probably wasn't really all
that necessary it is a good title and it
does kind of have something to do I mean
there is like a house that's cursed in a
cursed Village and [ __ ] like that so it
does kind of like apply but the poem
doesn't have anything to do with the
movie like I said it's basically like an
adaptation of the case of Charles Dick's
reward I mean it doesn't really matter
in the grand scheme of things because
I'm gonna say this is an excellent film
no matter what story it's based on so so
the always amazing Vincent Price uh
plays two roles here actually uh himself
and you know one role in like his
ancestor you know what I mean uh there's
also a supporting turn by Lon Chaney Jr
and uh appearances by a couple of Corman
regulars Elisha cook Jr he was that he
was in everything
um I saw in his Wikipedia page I think
that he's actually been in more uh I
think it was noir films like than any
other actor and I was like huh what do
you know but yeah he was in a [ __ ] ton
of like Roger Corman movies too and uh
Bruno vasoda he was also in a bunch he
has a very small role here but he's
always nice to see him uh in addition
this was the actress Deborah Paget I
guess it's Paget uh this was her final
film role she had been in like a bunch
of kind of biblical epics and stuff like
that she actually retired from acting
after this and became a born-again
Christian hosting her own show on the
Trinity Broadcasting Network which I
can't say that I've ever seen now I have
to give a special mention here of the
sets and like the matte paintings in
this movie which are all like completely
Lush and gorgeous uh the inside of the
Haunted Palace you know the titular
Palace in fact is actually even more
impressive than it appears because
um I actually found out that it was
actually much smaller than it looks on
screen Roger Corman actually used all of
these kind of uh you know film tricks
like shooting things in force
perspective to make it look gigantic and
the effect is Flawless like I would
never have known that if I hadn't looked
it up it looks like an enormous enormous
Castle so our Story begins in
1765. in this small village of Arkham
like I said this is the Lovecraft story
uh the townsfolk are very suspicious of
the man who lives in the palace on the
hill whose name is Joseph Kerwin uh
who's played by Vincent Price obviously
they actually suspect him of being in
League with the Devil
so one night they follow the seemingly
Bewitched young woman as she kind of
like walks all dazed and [ __ ] like
through the streets and up toward the
palace when she gets there uh Kerwin and
his mistress Hester tillingas too he
actually like stole from one of the
other like uh townsfolks so they're not
real happy about that they chained this
girl up in the basement and look like
they're getting ready to sacrifice her
like you find out later that's not
exactly what's happening but that looks
like what they're what they're gonna do
but uh one thing and another the
villagers eventually end up busting in
and drag Kerwin out uh and time to a
tree and set his ass on fire
so before he dies he curses the whole
town as you do uh as well as like the
future generations of its residents you
know what I mean just like you know like
curse you and your children and your
children's children and etc etc so 110
years later a man named Charles Dexter
Ward also Vincent Price uh and his wife
Ann show up in Arkham to have a look at
a property that they have inherited from
Ward's great great grandfather who of
course was Joseph Kerwin now obviously
it's gone through the family they don't
really go into like who owned it before
that they said no one's lived there for
a hundred years so I'm assuming it just
went through the family line and
everybody's like [ __ ] it I'm not living
there but you know what I mean so he
ends up with it and he's never even been
there so he goes into like he's looking
for directions and he goes in the tavern
in town which is called The Burning Man
so but then like Mr and Mrs Ward get a
whole room full of stink guy like from
all the denizens of the Town who believe
that Charles Ward is Joseph Kerwin like
returned or resurrected mostly because
he looks uncannily similar to the old
warlock as he's pictured in this like
kind of portrait that hangs in the
palace like they all like remember what
he looks like so all of the people in
the town too are like uh you know the
descendants of people that lived there
before that burned him alive you know
what I mean so although the arkhamites
if you want to call him that
um do their best to discourage the wards
from you know they just basically want
him to [ __ ] off uh the town doctor named
Dr Willett who's played by Frank Maxwell
he isn't superstitious at all and he
thinks all of this kind of occur stuff
is a bunch of Huey so he actually kindly
helps the couple find the palace which
to be fair is kind of like hard to miss
I mean it's just kind of like here's the
little village down here and here's this
big huge like looming castle like over
the town I'm like it's right there uh
obviously uh so Ward is basically like
well I don't think we'll be staying here
in Arkham especially since everybody's
being so [ __ ] rude to us but I mean
him and his wife at least kind of want
to take a little bit of a gander at the
house they inherited before they decide
what they're gonna do with it like maybe
they're gonna sell it or something like
that before they get up there though uh
they actually catch a glimpse of a
little girl without any eyes uh kind of
being herded along the main street by
her mother which is you know a little
bit disquieting to say the least I mean
the whole town is pretty weird like to
be honest I mean obviously everyone's
like really rude to them and [ __ ] like
that but you also see kind of glimpses
of this like one of the Town Elders
Edgar Whedon he's actually shown feeding
some raw meat to something someone
locked behind a door in his house and uh
also one time like when the wards go
into the village and they're walking
down the Main Street this whole Bevy of
like other mutated people like some of
them don't have any eyes some of them
don't have like an eye and a mouth and
they're all like [ __ ] up looking and
they kind of like come skulking out from
various places and like surround them
but they don't say anything or like
touch them or anything they just kind of
stay in there and like look menacing so
they're like that's a little strange so
when they get to the house uh the wards
actually end up crossing paths with the
very seemingly friendly Simon he's
played by Lon Cheney Jr he's like the
caretaker but it doesn't take too long
before Anne is creeped out by the old
place and it's like let's get the [ __ ]
out of here I don't like it Charles
agrees that the house is really spooky
he actually calls it a mausoleum but by
the time they got up there and
everything you know it's [ __ ] 1800 so
they had to take a carriage and whatnot
so like look it's like too late to you
know go back and go sleep somewhere else
now so we might as well stay the night
here because the caretaker laid out a
room for them and it's like then we'll
just sort everything out in the morning
we're probably not gonna stay here
problem is though that the malevolent
looking painting of Joseph Kerwin over
the mantle seems to have other ideas uh
it actually
appears that it's imbued with the spirit
of Joseph Kerwin who was a warlock and
as Charles stares at it like almost he
gets kind of hypnotized by it his
ancestor is actually able to take over
more and more of his personality or his
soul or whatever you want to call it
um now Charles is very strong-willed so
he's able to fight back against The
Invasion and so he does act normal
sometimes like he goes like in and out
uh but slowly though over the course of
the story Kerwin starts to take
possession of his great-great-grandson
and he vows that with this new body it's
like oh this time it works like you're
led to believe that he's been trying it
before like he tried to possess other
people it didn't work out so good but
he's like oh I got an ancestor this time
so it's so it totally worked and so he
wants to finish the task that he started
like more than a century ago which was
essentially using the Necronomicon to
summon the Elder gods and mating them
with human women remember how I said
they it seemed like they were going to
sacrifice that girl that wasn't whether
they were gonna do
so yeah the implication is a little
alarming uh so yeah so he wants to mate
the gods with human women so that he can
create a race of super beings it just
seems like everybody wants to do that
don't they sure now in this endeavor
Kerwin is actually aided by his faithful
servant Simon who I mentioned earlier
and another guy named Jabez now both of
these guys they're either Immortal or
I'm guessing maybe they also have
possessed their own ancestors just like
he did um that makes more sense now that
I'm thinking about it they don't really
explain it and he even manages to
resurrect his mistress Hester by digging
up her corpse at first they don't think
it's gonna work because they're like
she's way too far gone like she's real
[ __ ] up looking uh so I think the cup
the first couple times they do it it
fails but they do some Lovecraft Magic
on it and eventually she's back to her
uh living hot self again uh so this
little villain Squad here uh then goes
around killing some of the townspeople
like in Revenge for the whole Burning
Alive thing then it turns out that like
Anne Charles's wife and Dr Willett who
was like the only sympathetic
townsperson they apparently saved the
day though the ending of this makes it
pretty clear that Kerwin has not really
been defeated so there's that so as I
mentioned this is a really fun flick I
enjoyed this very very much uh it's
absolutely one of the best Corman films
of this era uh Vincent Price was
incredible as always
um playing both the very Wicked Joseph
Kerwin and you know the nice guy but
also like tormented uh Charles Ward
character like he and he did like a
really good job uh story moved along at
a good Pace it was never boring had an
awesome awesome set design I just loved
the interior of that castle and just had
this real cool like Gothic feel to it uh
special effects gotta say on the Elder
gods were you know you could tell that
they were uh pretty obviously hampered a
bit by the minuscule budget but you know
it's Roger Corman uh he was smart enough
to kind of keep the shots of the
monsters like pretty brief you you know
and kind of ambiguous and kind of focus
mainly on just like the lavish Interiors
the nice costumes and this the whole
like chilling atmosphere which is more
in line with like you know pose work and
lovecraft's work anyway they were more
atmosphere guys and that really comes
across here I mean it's not a super
super faithful adaptation of lovecraft's
Novella but I think it has enough
elements from the original story to
please kind of like Lovecraft purists
maybe and I think it actually captures
the spirit of lovecraft's work like
really really well
um so if you've seen corman's Poe
pictures I feel like a lot of people
have seen those
um and you want to see something just as
good as that but Lovecraft
um then definitely check this one out I
kind of feel like this one doesn't get
talked about as much as maybe some of
the other Poe ones but it's absolutely
worth your time I really really liked it
a lot and let me know what you thought
about it in the comments if you've seen
it did you even know that this was a
Lovecraft adaptation because I certainly
didn't I just thought it was another
like a another Poe one but it's not so
uh yeah if you haven't seen it check it
out I actually watched it on Amazon
Prime uh it's on there for free but I'm
sure you can stream it elsewhere if you
would like to so again let me know what
you thought about it in the comments and
then I'll do it for this flickers of
fear I'll see you guys again on the next
one bye